look I'm a Slytherin I'm not predisposed
to be kind fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald so I went into this not
expecting much and what I got was still
somehow disappointing isn't it funny how
a movie that you do not think will be
good still manages to let you down and
no that's not an indicator that is
actually worse than what I thought it
was gonna be but rather that I saw the
potential of how it could have worked
and they still missed it there is a good
movie in here actually I think more
accurately there's at least two good
movies in here if not three which is
kind of at the heart of what really
doesn't work about this film there are
things that are good or could have been
good given the breathing room and the
pacing they needed but there are too
many plots too many elements too many
characters too many storylines piling up
on top of each other until they all just
sort of meld together and they just the
whole thing suffocates under the weight
of all of this there is just too much
and especially considering that there's
stuff that happens towards the end that
is clearly meant to have emotional
resonance and in a properly paced film
that had focused on the characters more
thoroughly that this residence is
supposed to be coming from probably
would have but here it doesn't because
what needed to be done the work that
needs to be done in the time that needed
to be spent in order for those moments
to have the emotional resonance the
movie wants them to have all that gets
muscled aside in order to fit in the
four five six I don't even know how many
other frigging plots there are and what
I say there's too much going on here
that doesn't mean I think it's confusing
I could follow it fine I just couldn't
connect with any of it because it didn't
stick with it long enough plus there's
also plot holes how
friggin but on this thing I would bet
money that there is at least half an
hour of cut material out of this if not
45 minutes and I can exemplify this with
one character technically this could
count as a spoiler but I seriously don't
think it does and when I explain this
you'll understand why there is a
character whose name I don't even
remember he's a follower of Grendel Volf
he has two scenes in the movie one scene
where he is giving some information to
Grindelwald and seems to be kind of
wavering we're not entirely sure if it's
because he's afraid of Grendel Vault if
he's questioning the their purpose and
their goals we don't really know but he
seems a little bit iffy and then later
at the end of the movie he gets killed
bright by Grindelwald who was this guy
why was he unnerved
why did Grendel Valda filled that need
to kill him no idea like there's no
reason for him to be here at all in any
way shape or form he serves zero actual
function he provides a little bit of
information to grid the vault but
seriously I will bet you he had an
entire subplot that was cut and the
reason that he's here at all is because
he happened to be the one giving this
information that they still had to show
Grindelwald getting and then they're
like well I guess we keep the end of his
story too but like you don't give a
character two scenes and expect that to
have any meaning whatsoever especially
when they are at the extreme far ends of
the runtime but that's kind of what I'm
getting at here now before I like start
to really drill into any specific stuff
because that is gonna constitute what
could Jim Moore genuinely be considered
to be spoilers let me talk about what
does work now a lot of what I'm gonna
talk about a little bit later is stuff
that would have worked but didn't as
presented but there are a few things
that do actually work honestly the
performances are all good there is not a
bad performance in the film and I also
kind of want to revise what I said about
Newt Scamander as a care
or when I did my review of the first
fantastic piece I my opinion of that
film overall has not changed but I I was
rougher on Newt than I should have been
I've come to a better appreciation and
understanding of what is being done with
him as a hero and as a type of hero and
he's actually grown on me so I quite
like him and that's not me going like
he's better than this one no he's pretty
much exactly the same
I just appreciate what they do with him
more now than I did back when I saw the
the first fantastic piece and when I did
my review of that film the characters
who were good before are still good that
means Jacob and Queenie are highlights
us a lot of the new characters are quite
good Lita Lestrange is surprisingly good
news brother pretty damn good so that
you know no one is giving a bad
performance there's a couple of bland or
unremarkable performances again I do
have to wonder how much of that is
talked up - I bet you that there were
two or three extra scenes these
characters had that just hit the cutting
room floor but there's one thing that Oh
Jude Law as good as he as a young
Dumbledore he saw actually we could we
get a number of other characters who we
either know or have had referenced in
the in the main series and if those were
actually kind of cool most of those were
pretty a well-integrated except for one
which was stupid and pointless but I'll
come back to that one so the thing that
I actually think was the strongest
element it was the one thing that I
think got as much screen time as it
needed in order to work and I was
shocked that I that I feel this worked
as well as it did cuz I this was
something that I was really super
expecting to hate that's Grindelwald
himself he actually works really really
well with as a villain I really like the
person they're taking with him and
Johnny Depp's performance is well it's a
Johnny Depp performance you know when
you get what it says on the box and I
I would complain about that except when
I actually stop and think about the
adult actors and the Harry Potter
franchise the vast majority of them are
basically just cast to be them not and
while not be themselves but to give what
is the standard performance you tend to
think of when you think of that actor so
I can't really begrudge Johnny Depp that
when I was prepared to give a pass to
all the other actors who were in the
main series so moving on from like him
specifically in terms of the approach
that is done with a grand involved what
I really like and what I think does a
lot to distinguish him from Voldemort
cuz I was certain he was just gonna be a
Voldemort knockoff even though yes I
know chronologically he comes first but
like that doesn't matter order of
release matters so what I like is that
there is a surprising amount of effort
and time put into making it clear the
way in which he gathers a following the
way that he appeals to people who he
targets and how he goes about figuring
out what are the things about them
that I can appeal to that will get them
over to my way of thinking it's actually
really well done it's really well done
on one on one character basis he has got
kind of a speech rally kind of thing
towards the end of the movie that's
quite well done like I and I don't think
they cross the line into actually making
him appealing as a character which is so
there's something like the American
History X problem where you're showing
someone's expectable is despicable but
by showing the charisma of that person
you actually make this despicable thing
appealing I don't actually think it
crosses that line but it does present it
in a way that you're like okay I get why
some people actually would follow this
guy and the reason I say that's a really
good distinction Baltimore is one of the
odd things about Voldemort if you go
back and look at the the original Harry
Potter series is that it's not it's well
I was gonna say it's not clear I mean
you kind of know but like it's hard to
believe that people are following him
because they like him and they believe
in him like I get the sense that his
followers some of them believe in what
they
what they think he will make happen but
like all the followers around him either
appear to be just atrocious human beings
who like Voldemort because serving him
gives them a chance to be atrocious or
they are terrified of him nobody seems
to nobody who isn't you know insane
yeah like Bellatrix Lestrange they don't
seem happy about following him and and
that's not and to be clear that's not
actually a plot hole in the original
Harry Potter series because most of his
followers he would have accumulated
actually way before that series is set
back during his initial uprising and we
don't see any of that so it's not
actually a plot hole I just I just don't
really know how he accumulated those
people and seeing how he is around them
in the points that we do seem and the
series is like oh boy he wouldn't be a
great boss what is cool about
Grindelwald is you do see that you do
see how he can gather and appeal to
these people and it makes him a
distinctly different beast from just
being super powerful and monstrous which
is what Voldemort is which is not to say
that groan of old is not monstrous he is
but they sort of add that little bit of
honey to it where you again you get
white people who might not automatically
be inclined to just be totally on board
with his ideas might fall under his
spell for lack of a better term so yeah
I think that's the single best handled
element in the film overall but from
here I'm gonna get on the complaint
train I think pretty soon um
Oh before I get there you know what
visually it's it's still pretty good I
there is a little bit more color and it
mostly when we're in sort of newts
menagerie sort of settings but the the
visual inventiveness of the world is
still present that's nice I don't love
the way some of it is shot like the
thing opens with an action scene that
yeah you know I I know you think it's
more dramatic to put an action scene in
the middle of a thunderstorm but you can
barely see a frigging thing that's going
on and so
things like that but overall it looks
good the creatures are cool both
conceptually and visually so I was down
for all that the nifflas are back and
those are adobo I I went with Liz she
wasn't up for for joining me for this
review but she she did she did squeak at
the at the net like not just like like
legitimately several times up the
nibblers so you know they're back there
cute there are some new creatures which
are kind of cool and and there's some
flashback stuff that is just sort of
it's nice and nostalgic because there's
some flashback stuff satyr how it works
which kind of makes you know oh yeah
cool so yeah there's all that now I'm
gonna start getting complaining so I
feel like the the movie like I said that
there was more than one movie taking
place here and the movie that I want to
see oh I'm probably gonna start getting
into spoilers at this point so overall
like if you're super invested in in
Harry Potter and the Wizarding World go
ahead check it out make your own opinion
but this is not gonna convert anybody
not a chance in heck so and you know I
I'm not gonna promise you a good time
even if you are super into Harry Potter
which I am so the the storyline that I
found myself the most intrigued by and
also felt super hacked to the bone was
actually that of credence Ezra Miller's
character first of all thank God they
got rid of that did a horrendously
stupid haircut they had him in last time
but I was actually really interested in
his story because he had in many ways
almost like an anakin skywalker's turned
to the dark side kind of story going on
but it was such a minor footnote in
everything else that was happening it's
so like in the early part of the film we
just find out that oh yeah no he didn't
die at the end
okay and now all of a sudden while he's
in Paris okay and he's working at a
wizard circus and kind of an a freak
show thing okay and he's made friends
with this woman who it turns out is
Nagini
yeah Voldemort's snake but she's a woman
right now and yeah like that's a that's
a that's a lot to skip over that's a lot
to go so to go from you know basically
just skip how he survived how he crossed
the Atlantic because he didn't have the
means of the funds and he doesn't really
know how to use the what powers he does
have yet how did he end up in this place
how did he make this connection with
this woman and here's the thing I'm not
asking these questions going and I don't
care about the answer I actually kind of
do I think it would have been quite
fascinating to get into the head of this
character because he's going through so
much questioning he doesn't really know
who he is or and barely understands what
he is he doesn't know his own history
the reason he's in Paris is to try and
figure out who he is because he has no
idea and you get a tremendous and you
get a pretty strong sense of the
conflict going on and him and the
confusion then the just trying to reach
out and find anything to latch on to and
honestly if you hadn't made a movie that
focused primarily on that and maybe
legal a strangest story because they are
thematically similar and they kind of
come to a head those two stories cross
paths at the end of the movie in a way
that is very super clunky because the
way it gets exposition is a character
explains it and then another character
basically revises that explanation and
then we get an extra twist at the very
end which meant nothing to me because by
then I was just numb to this there's
there's some seriously bad exposition
dumps in this movie which again are
things that should have been shown if
they were going to be there and I
suspect they were done in the form of
exposition because it got stuff
done faster way in order to fit all of
the various things going on into it oh
you know what it's worth touching on
Dumbledore and Dumbledore and
Grindelwald specifically because this
was an element that I have complained
about in more than one video given you
know the fact that JK Rowling and David
Yates the director had said that they
were not going to address what Rowling
has been claiming for the last decade or
so that Dumbledore is a gay man and was
in love with her in the vault now what
we get in here actually does support
that it doesn't make it explicit but
what we have here I actually don't have
any complaints about and I feel was
solid in regards to that particular
element in terms of hinting it and
Dumbledore himself has a line that is a
pretty relevant line which is that a guy
from the Ministry of Magic oh quick
question has there ever been any member
of the Ministry of matte of magic higher
than like ground level like working
stiff type that hasn't been a complete
and utter douchebag because I don't
think there hasn't been or I don't think
there has been or at whatever too many
negatives yeah there's a review in a
nutshell
but anyway so I he's got this thing
where he's confronting this guy and the
guy says to Dumbledore you were like
brothers and doubles as we were closer
than brothers and that is a decent line
to hinder the connection that they had
now given that what is in here does
appear to hint towards it my strong
suspicion is that this was added as a
pickup this was added in reshoots after
JK Rowling and David Yates got chewed
out for their assertion that the movie
wasn't gonna tackle that because what's
in here is enough to claim that it is
being addressed in some manner and no I
don't think it was caught unquote
preserving the surprise because what's
the support we knew about this
connection for a long time before and
the people that you told that you
weren't gonna do it were people who were
expecting you to do it so no it wasn't
like trying to preserve spoilers or
anything like that I think this was
probably added in as a as a corrective
and you know I'm setting aside my belief
how this ended up in the movie what is
in the movie is pretty good it's fine as
far as addressing that particular issue
cups but you know the the stuff with so
like I said Lita and grievances story
they were the ones that I wanted to see
more of the most because and again there
was a thematic similarity to them
because they're both going through
issues of trying to find connections and
having tenuous or questionable links to
their own past and so those two stories
complement each other really well
unfortunately those stories have
absolutely no bearing on what is going
on with Newt and what is going on with
Jacob and what is going on with Queenie
and what is going on with Tina and what
is going on with Dumbledore or honestly
Grindelwald even really so you know all
this stuff it just it just piles up it's
just too freakin much and you know what
in addition to the whole credence thing
there's another element that from the
end of the previous movie just gets
tossed aside which is Jacob shows up
early in the movie and he's just like
and they and Newt goes oh I thought they
remember got why he's like nah didn't
take him really that's how we're like
I'm not saying you can't do that and I
like having Jacob back he was one of my
favorite characters in the last movie
and he's still good here but like that's
your explanation oh no it wasn't that it
didn't work yeah yeah things like that
and how Creedence gets really rushed to
may even being alive and then to where
he is at the start of this movie the
whole thing right now between this and
the previous fantastic beast it feels
like it's being made up as a one as it
goes along now I don't know how
thoroughly JK Rowling worked out the
entirety of the Harry Potter series when
she start writing it and in the early
parts but regardless of how much he did
or didn't plan in advance the Harry
Potter series
felt like something that had been
planned and advanced it felt like things
that were being laid out because they
were gonna matter later it felt like
things that were closed off because that
that story was complete and we're gonna
focus on other stuff now this doesn't
feel like that this feels like sequels
cobbled together on dealing doing one at
a time basis and not really having a
firm plan because you don't open a movie
but immediately going oh remember these
two major things that happened in the
action climax and then the emotional
climax of the film yeah forget them
we're just totally negating them that's
crap storytelling in terms of a flow
from entry in a series to entry in a
series especially if you're claiming to
do a continuing story across multiple
entries that's just bad and again
regardless of how much planning is or
isn't going on ahead of time it
certainly feels like there is not a lot
and I yeah like that's the doesn't thing
this movie it's not bad but it is
frustrating I see glimpses of the things
that I know that I loved about this
series I see elements and stories and
characters that could have been in good
stories
if they were properly focused I think
honestly at this point in many ways I
feel like JK Rowling's decision in the
main Harry Potter franchise to limit the
perspective to Harry I mean it's not in
first person but I mentioned this before
that basically with the exception of the
occasional flashback but even those are
done through the pen Steve so we're
still getting Harry's perspective on
that flashback or you know the prologue
scenes at the end at the beginning of
each book it's always limited to what
Harry is seeing what Harry's
experiencing what Harry is thinking and
anything else that he finds that has to
be told to him by other characters so I
think that in many ways was kind of a
benefit to Jake hero because it forced
her to be focused
whereas here because the narrative is
freed up and not restricted to the
perspective of a single primary
character we have all these stories
sprawling out and tumbling over tripping
over
each other and I think the lack of
restrictions has just brought out some
tendencies that need to be reined in
when it comes to Rowling's writing
because a lot of these things that I'm
talking about probably have interesting
backstories and our interesting ideas
and could tell and could be good stories
but she can't focus she can't focus into
a single strong central narrative
purpose and you know again I on it I
just think she shouldn't be writing
these scripts she's not a script writer
she's a novelist because if you want to
compare the movies to the books the
books me and are a heck of a lot because
you can put a lot more in the books
you're not restricted in time in terms
of how long you have to tell something
in a book the way you are in a film you
can take you can take little
divergencies little divergences for the
sake of a chapter I mean that's that is
why the majority board is cut from the
Harry Potter movies is all the classroom
stuff you only get a handful of them in
the movies you get a ton of them in the
books because there's this space for
them but now she is writing in a medium
that doesn't allow her to have these
many things all spread out when it needs
to be confined to this amount of time
I'm not saying she shouldn't be coming
up with the story because I do think
there is stuff in this story there are
stories worth telling I'm actually
getting fairly engaged in these
characters in the overall story but the
way it's being presented just does not
work someone else has to be writing the
scripts for these things Oh instead I'd
come back to it so yeah
Nagini the snake is a woman you know why
other people aside for me I've already
pointed out why this is like a weird
problematic thing in and of itself given
the fact that you know she's probably
well she or casting or whoever made the
decision it's probably going for
diversity points because they cast an
Asian actress and like that's fine but
now we run into while the subservient
Asian stereotypes so that doesn't help
but even setting that aside he was
setting all that crap aside we do why
why is she there again if you had
focused on greetings a story and built
that connection between the two of them
maybe I understand why she was there but
since yet didn't I don't know she serves
zero plot function absolutely none and
there isn't enough breathing room for
her to have relevance as an emotional
core there's no reason for her to be in
this huh it's like it's like somebody's
compiling Pottermore entries and trying
to make a movie out of those and they're
good ideas and there could be good
stories made out of what is going on
here but this isn't it not bad but
frustrating fantastic beasts the crimes
of Grindelwald have you seen it what do
you think about it whatever your
thoughts are drop something down in the
comments let's talk about it whole bunch
of stuff you can do because there's
buttons and there's links including one
to my patreon if you feel like
supporting me that way but if you don't
don't worry about it other links you can
check out but if you don't want to do
that either don't sweat it cuz at the
end of the day you're the council I just
run the meaning so until next time this
council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]